panel un peu
chamboulé en os de verre plus haut dans
l'émission parler entre autres des
masques parler de choc on va prendre le
temps je vous présente d'abord mais
pénale et stéphanie et chouinard est là
michel ces objets et on est très heureux
d'accueillir jonathan trudeau analystes
politiques animateur à cogeco bonsoir
jonathan bienvenue à ce panel
merci très courte et le joindre si la
vitesse aux cadres très bien tour de
table sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre
quand même pour une presse qui est
annoncée à la dernière minute de
monsieur trudeau bon après monsieur
buydens chelsea je commence avec vous ce
n'est pas étonnant ce que le canada
annonce je le disais présence militaire
accrue
sanctions en même temps celui qui est
peut-être le moins étonné c'est vladimir
poutine ce soir
ou écouter quelqu'un décide qu'il que
les normes de la communauté
internationale qui quittent les malheurs
de des nations unies etc qui vont faire
qu'à sa tête il n'y a pas grand chose
qui doit le dérangeait beaucoup ça mais
c'est surréaliste discours d'hier ce
pays il aurait pas dû exister écidément
qui est juste ou du pays le plus ancien
que moscou ont peut-être que ça faisait
que le pays existe à vos besoins il
arrive quelque chose qui marchait pas
alors qu'à kehl que refusent les normes
c'est ce qui arrive doit arriver c'est à
dire 10 les occidentaux avaient prévu
des sanctions ils pourront les faire on
verra en mesure si ça finit par avoir un
effet sur le subtil et quand quelqu'un
un plaidoyer émotif comme celui d'hier
rien c'est pas que tu es tout sauf
rationnelle en fait mais c'est un
plaidoyer motifs sur le retour la russie
doit se relever on a été bafoué depuis
dans les années 90 2 c'est ce cocktail
qui peut être dangereux à voir jonathan
trudeau bon le canada on est limité mon
répond comme on peut répondre j'imagine
mais je pense que c'est dans l'ordre des
choses que le canada emboîtent le pas et
aux états unis ou aux partenaires de
l'otan évidemment on se contente pas de
montrer aux personnes qui pensent que le
canada va faire trembler mais
l'aspect moderne des conflits et joue
politique c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
qui évidemment craignent des
affrontements sur le terrain j'ai
l'impression que plus on va avancer
heures au cours des années avec la
globalité l'économie on va davantage
assister à des espèces de guerre froide
perpétuel où la façon de faire le plus
mal à l'adversaire ce sera par le biais
de sanctions économiques le canada qui
s'inscrit dans cette lignée là et ce
sera de voir jusqu'à quel point vladimir
poutine aurons une tolérance élevée vous
parlez d'émotivité patrice master peu
l'aspect qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on veut
tout sauf de l'immotique de l'émotivité
dans des conflits aussi eux aussi aussi
important exactement c'est fanny
chouinard cet engrenage
en tout cas il est en mouvement
difficile de reculer quand on avance
comme ça ouais d'autant plus que bon on
parle de sanctions économiques qui ont
été imposées par le canada et les alliés
il ya quand même déjà eu des décès il ya
eu des morts hier ont rapporté que cinq
ukrainiens avaient été tués par les
forces russes parce que soi disant ils
avaient traversé la frontière et qui s
était potentiellement des saboteurs donc
une raison que très peu de personnes
croient sur la scène internationale donc
on voit déjà que en plus du discours
d'hier soir qui était tout à fait
surréaliste la part du président on est
déjà rendu ailleurs on est déjà rendu
vers un potentiel qui dépasse tranche
mans le les sanctions économiques et
est-ce qu'on est équipé des dernières
questions après cela je vais revenir à
nos autres sujets mais est-ce qu'on est
équipé en europe aux etats-unis au
canada incidemment pour répondre à ce
que fait poutine actuellement jonathan
on a l'impression qu'on est quand même
relativement et puis ça on n'enverra pas
de soldats l'année très dure
pour ce qui est du canada 2 gelé
l'influencé est plutôt est limité il
reste que quand on regarde les forces de
l'union européenne les états unis
évidemment qui ont un poids important
dans la balance et le canada je pense
que c'est la force du nombre qui
éventuellement pourraient faire flancher
la demo piscine je parlais de sanctions
économiques lorsqu'on parle par exemple
de toutes les notions d'énergie on a vu
l'allemagne qui suspend un projet fort
important pour pour les russes je pense
que c'est comme ça qu'on va être capable
avec les pays alliés vont capable de
mettre une pression qui peut-être elle
saura t'elle être suffisante pour faire
stopper les les intentions de l'admirer
michel ses fans est le nerf de la guerre
on je n'attends parle avec raison de ce
pipeline qui construit enfin il pas tout
à fait finie mais presse ça c'est de
l'argent ça peut faire mal chef
ça ça peut faire mal et la deuxième
étape des sanctions qui n'a pas été
commandé encore par les occidentaux
c'est dire parfait mais vous vous
retirez du système bancaire
international aux cartes de crédit
marcheront plus nulle part décidemment
la dette souveraine de la russie ne vous
pourrez plus emprunter sur les marchés
ça ça peut faire très mal mais encore
une fois c'est à terme c'est pas le
premier jour ce que le deuxième jour
monsieur musée n'a presque plus de
réserves en dollars américains et un
oeil à un euro monnaie chinoise alors il
s'est préparé pour cela alors il ya une
limite à ce que les sections monde est
un peu faim puis il faut pas oublier
qu'à partir du moment où monsieur bart
hayden team je n'avais pas de trou puis
a pas d'affrontement militaire c'est
aussi ce négoce à faire qui puisse sur
la table ouais stéphanie l'argent car m
cc c'est un ce gazoduc et c'est
extrêmement important pour les allemands
pour les russes bien sûr qu'ils
voulaient vendre
c'est quand même des grosses poignées la
wii dans ce qui s'est passé dans les 24
dernières heures c'est clair et net que
c'est la décision de l'allemagne qui
fait le plus mal de toutes les sanctions
qui ont été imposées jusqu'à maintenant
c'est vraiment
allemagne qui vient a sonné un coup le
plus dur à la russie entre temps que
michel viens de mentionner puisqu'il est
annoncé jusqu'à maintenant il y aurait
quand même une option mitoyenne
c'est-à-dire d'imposer à ce qu'on fait
actuellement dans les deux régions de
donetsk est lougansk de l'imposer à la
russie au complet c'est-à-dire d'imposer
aux canadiens de ne plus investir dans
quelques domaines que ce soit dans
l'économie russe bon évidemment si c'est
seulement canada qui prend cette
direction là ça va être très limité mais
si c'est un si ça se fait d'un commun
accord avec tous les alliés de l'otan à
ce moment là ça pourrait avoir un impact
sur très bien pour l'ukraine on vient
chez nous
des masques à l'école terminée le cette
marche au québec mais je vous fais
entendre le débat sur les mesures
janvier eu débat canadien qu'on a suivi
beaucoup débat québécois l'opposition
demande à monsieur legault de lever
l'état d'urgence qui donne des pouvoirs
au gouvernement pour des contraintes ses
terres on écoute et on revient
j'ai l'impression que le premier
ministre veut le beurre et l'argent du
beurre
c'est à dire il nous dit je veux plus
faire de point de presse de gestion de
crise parce qu'on n'est plus en état de
crise danseur dans ce cas là qu'on lève
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
prévenez se veut continuer à gouverner
seul par décrets n'aient pu avoir à
répondre à des questions habitante des
journalistes
aujourd'hui au québec il ya personne qui
pense qu'on est en urgence sanitaire la
personne qui pense qu'on devrait arrêter
la démocratie en fait on devrait la
faire fonctionner c'est la
responsabilité du premier ministre parce
que le parti libéral est d'accord pour
payer des primes aux infirmières oui est
ce que le parti libéral est d'accord
pour garder ne passe pas au vaccinale
pendant encore quelques semaines oui est
ce que le parti libéral est d'accord
qu'on embauche des gens qui ont
peut-être pas les mêmes qualifications
qui était prévu une convention
collective pour vacciner le parti
libéral est d'accord pour être capable
de faire tous nos besoins d'urgence
center
alors le gouvernement plein qu'il a
encore besoin viens de l'entendre
jonathan trudeau et il était efficace
dans son plaidoyer
mais je pense que le gouvernement répète
toujours le même message c'est à dire
que s'il médecine d'urgence sanitaire
c'est pour des raisons bien précis je
pense que lorsqu'il évoque par exemple
les primes versées aux infirmières ou
d'être capable d'imposer le port du
masque encore dans certains endroits les
gens peuvent comprendre que peut-être
encore une certaine nécessité je
comprends également que les gens watts
qu'on passe à d'autres choses mais moi
ce que je me questionne patrice c'est
sûr logement caisse mais je me
questionne c'est sur l'insistance des
partis d'opposition a toujours ramené ce
concept low qui on va se dire est un peu
abstrait en ce sens où les québécois qui
nous écoutent leur depuis quelques temps
de plus en plus sont capables de sortir
de la maison de vaquer à leurs
occupations
y a pas d'urgence sanitaire qui leur
pèse sur les épaules à chaque jour
lorsqu'il se lève et on a l'impression
d'entendre plus le même message qu'on
avait entendu avant
hockey michel
c'est plus une question de commodité
pour le gouvernement une obligation
le couvert de ma pourrait continuer à
donner des primes aux infirmières ci
avait pas urgence sanitaire l'ontario
sans dépasser la grenouille mécanique ça
m'est passé mais c'est facile c'est
commode et
nationales du titre change rien depuis
toute façon alors pourquoi s'en priver
mais c'est vraiment de la commodité
plutôt qu'une obligation ses fans et à
écouter c'est certain qu'on regarde ça
de l'ontario qui on se dit qu'il ya
certainement une autre façon de gérer la
chose je penses cali les partis de
l'opposition qui pose des questions
quand à
à la fin finalement du gouvernement par
décret ce sont des questions importantes
qui sont peut-être abstraite mais il
faut quand même voir le que ça fait plus
de cent jours maintenant que
l'opposition ne peut pas faire son
travail dans l'assemblée législative
donc si l'urgence sanitaire est terminée
bien qu'on en revienne à des débats
comme comme ça devrait être le cas
d'habitude le masque j'en parlais ça a
été annoncé aujourd'hui on doit en
parler plus tôt masque en revenant du
congé scolaire il n'y a pas grand monde
qui va s'opposer à saint-michel si
je penserais pas surtout qu'ils vont
garder le masque la musique dans les
aires communes de l'école c'est un
casque on vous le retirez la dernière à
deux derniers endroits où on va lui
retirer les masques c'est les airs qu'au
vu des écoles transports en commun c'est
assez évident alors c'est le début de la
fête du basket mais ce n'est pas la fin
du match j'en attends
moi ce que je j'observe c'est davantage
dans la façon à laquelle on a procédé
pour faire cette annonce c'est à dire on
vient vraiment le démonter que le
gouvernement souhaite se retirer d'une
gestion aux comptes au quotidien d'une
pandémie on avait vu françois legault
qui petit à petit ne citez pas
nécessairement au point de presse de son
ministre de santé malon de carrément
annoncé le retrait d'une mesure qui
était quand même significatif fort
importante par voie de communiqué en
répondant par la suite aux questions des
journalistes m'ont dit que vraiment le
gouvernement veut tranquillement pas
vite s'effacer des programmes eu un peu
la population qui était rendu
indépendante de ces interventions
hebdomadaires et démontrer que vraiment
on s'en va graduellement vers autre
chose c'est ça en cours de l'autre côté
on ne veut plus faire les intentions les
annonces deviennent plus près visé mais
stéphanie politiquement c'est clair que
le gouvernement le gouffre se retirer de
ce qui était perçu comme étant
l'interface public de toutes les
décisions on veut laisser à docteur
boileau maintenant le soin de faire des
points de presse oui effectivement on
voit qui le gouvernement est de moins en
moins présents sur la place publique et
de moins en moins présents ici pour
justifier certaines des décisions qui
sont prises ce serait intéressant de
voir en ontario si on fait la danse deux
qu'on a vu depuis le début de la
pandémie s'est adossé deux fois de ne
pas décider de suivre le gouvernement du
québec dans ce type de décision lens qui
a créé au masque dans les écoles pour le
moment rien entendu à ce sujet l'homme
et c'est quelque chose qu'on surveille
jean charest va-t-il se lancer
christian noël notre collègue que
j'invite à se joindre à nous et une
seconde vous avez fait un texte matin
bon vous allez plus loin que d'autres en
dix ans mais là il veut ça je pense
qu'on peut s'entendre qui lui qu'il veut
bien ils se préparent activement les
appuis s'accumulent c'est pas du tout le
même film qu'il y a deux ans comme sien
pas du tout monsieur charest semble
avoir l'impression qui reçoit davantage
d'appuis la question de questions à se
poser avant de se lancer au leadership 1
est ce qu'il veut et ça ça te répond
cela semble être oui la question
suivante c est ce qu ils peuvent gagner
et c'est là où monsieur charest attend
de voir quelles vont être les règles à
la course à la direction du parti
conservateur avant de donner son ouïe
finale parce qu'il peut encore changer
d'idée vous vous tiendrez la dernière
fois avec vous patrice on avait entendu
jusqu'à la dernière minute et finalement
ça avait été un nom dans cette même
course à la direction conservatrice en
2000 à 2020 pour remplacer andrew scheer
qui a fait lire rental pierre poilievre
qui est maintenant candidat lui aussi se
préparait à faire son annonce il y avait
même réservé une salle communautaire
dans sa circonscription et la veille on
nous envoyait des textos pour nous dire
c'est annulé je changerais encore la
possibilité d'un doublé mais il veut il
s'enquit la lettre qui a été publiée
dans les journaux ce matin avec
plusieurs députés plusieurs membres du
parti conservateur de plusieurs
provinces différentes
c'est un peu pour flatter l'égo de
monsieur charest aussi pour créer comme
genre de momentum pour lui dire voyez on
vous déroule le tapis rouge là le canada
a besoin de vous comment la personne qui
a été choisi pour être le sauveur du
parti libéral au québec pour résister un
appel pour être le sauveur du canada et
du parti conservateur au canada c'est un
peu pour ça que monsieur reyes par
exemple avait plein de bonnes choses à
dire sur monsieur monsieur charest très
bien oui on va écouter monsieur
réellement bien pas non c'est clair je
serai le plus heureux s'ils avaient dit
oui mais je vous confirme que non sa
réflexion avance cependant ce serait
malhonnête de vous dire que je ne lui
parle pas
je lui parle mais je pense que c'est une
grande réflexion pour lui pour sa
famille je peux comprendre qu'ils
veulent peser le pour et le contre
prendre le temps de de faire la bonne
réflexion mais ultime ans il décide de
se lancer il y aura des soldats comme
moi qui seront à ses côtés pour pouvoir
livrer bataille gagner la course à la
chefferie d'après ce dernier le rôle de
premier ministre noda
jonatha il a le goût je pense que c'est
dans lui c'est dans son adn
est ce que les conditions cette fois ci
sont réunies pour qu'il ya un
mois j'ai l'impression que de plus en
plus les conditions sont réunies les
sillons démontre qu'il est tout à fait
favorable qu'il a envie de faire le saut
ils cochent plusieurs cases en ce moment
là je pense que l'appui des membres du
caucus conservateur du québec lé de
façon assez claire à 6 majoritaire s'est
beaucoup d influence au niveau
organisationnel il voit qu'il ya des
gens qui sont en place que je pense à
trotter des militants libéraux
provinciaux un peu désabusé qui ont
envie de se lancer donc resteront les
règles les règles de la course et la
lettre de ce matin sincèrement je pense
pas que c'était nécessairement pour
convaincre monsieur charest pour
davantage faire un contrepoids à
l'espèce de tonalité négative qu'on
entend au québec là certains vont parler
du passif de monsieur charest ait des
gens qui ont voulu dire attendez le yop
du négatif à dire sur le sujet on va
vous le rappeler ce matin stéphanie il
n'y avait pas de plus dans l'ouest dans
cette lettre on dit que ça viendra
peut-être
c'est important qu'ils ne soient pas
perçues comme états le candidat du
caucus du québec non plus non d'autant
plus qu'elle soit ça pourrait lui nuire
le jour du vote puisque depuis la
dernière la dernière course à la
chefferie il ya eu un changement dans
les règlements au sein du parti
conservateur c'est à dire que dans une
circonscription s'y opposent 100 membres
la circonscription ne voudra pas 100
points comme c'était le cas auparavant
il ya plusieurs circonscriptions au
québec où il y aura du travail de terre
un sérieux à faire jour l'équipe de
monsieur charest pour s'assurer que
toutes les circonscriptions le si elle
vote charest vont valoir la totalité des
points mais c'est certain qu'il ya du
travail à faire dans l'ouest on voit
qu'il ya quand même hein
une vague de fond qui se passe au sein
du parti conservateur
une vague n'importe qui sauf pierre
poilievre et ça ça pourrait franchement
à aider monsieur charest a rallié les
forces plus centre droite même au delà
de ce qu'on a vu dans l'appui de ce
matin c'est à dire du nouveau brunswick
jusqu'à l'ontario celle sur gc on
vassili vol silva on va assister à
vraiment un duel énorme entre les deux
gros qu'un de ce parti là
je parle bien sûr conservateur qui m'ont
écrit m'ont dit aujourd'hui attaché
matin sur ses pas et l'est effectivement
chez poignet mais vous n'avez pas dans
l'est et dans les dents d habitude de
dire je ne peux pas
l'attaquer directement je vais pas ne
pas attaquer très fort mais je saurai me
répondrait force qui peut attendre le
champ rescrit peut les dissuader c'est
une seule chose c'est des règles de la
course si par exemple la course avait dû
l'enjeu ce qui n'est pas impossible
surtout que c'est un mode postale ça ça
voudrait dire qu'on n'a pas le temps de
faire rentrer du monde de faire signer
des cartes de membres là ça devient des
plus périlleux sur la fin mais autrement
c'est sa dernière chance il le sait il
l'a vu lui toute sa vie il faut y aller
c'est mais il faut aussi avoir une
organisation il faut avoir une
organisation qui est pas celle qu'ils
avaient du temps où il était au parti
libéral en 92 on faisait pas campagne
sur instagram sûreté ctaq techtoc une
cité pas alors il faut vraiment que lui
s'habituer à cette nouvelle façon de
faire de faire de la politique et
surtout de la politique au détail comme
quand on fait aucun cas donner des
conseils chez free jonathan est écrit
c'est en terminant est ce que je lis
beaucoup et j'entends déjà dit il faut
que s'il y va que d'autres candidats de
sade de son call de plus entre pas trop
à droite il y avait comme tâche
acridienne et compagnie pas si un
deuxième tour c'est des voix qui
pourraient se reporter sur lui un
jonathan
exactement ceci le changement auquel ont
assisté dans les dents les derniers
jours alors on voulait tout le monde
signifie d'emblée derrière le char et
mais on se rend compte que plus on va
vite organisation qui on est capable
d'aller chercher des nouveaux membres et
éventuellement s'unir derrière monsieur
charest c'est peut-être la meilleure
wood passage bon ben c'est très bien
c'est comme ça que ça se termine ce soir
christian on lit votre texte sur notre
site très intéressant publié à londres
ce matin stéphane et michel jonaz tard
bienvenus à très bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit